[music]
good day ladies and gentlemen
andrea nahles made a
profound decision today
both for herself personally and for
the social democratic party of
germany
i would like to express my respect for
the decision of andrea nahles i
have worked with her for many years
both as
federal minister for  work and social affairs
as well as party and
parliamentary group leader
i have always done
that in a spirit of trust and it was always absolutely reliable what
we discussed with each other she is a
passionate social democrat you
can say that
but i also find her a fine
character of course i also have
respect  Before the decisions that
the social democratic party
must now make regarding the successor to
Andrea Nahles,
regardless of this, I want to
say for the government that we will
continue the work of the government with all
seriousness and, above all
, with great
responsibility  awareness
because the issues we have to solve
are on the table both in the
federal republic of germany here
at home and in euros
as well as of course i think about the
situation in the world and in
this spirit we will continue but thank you very much